من الرياض يلتحق بنا المختص في سوق
الاموال والاسهم انس الراجحي سيد انس مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في النشره الرابعه من
الرياض موجه من المكاسب بدايه العام مؤشر
تداول السعودي قاربت 14 نقطه ثم تدبدب حتى
وصل الى حاجز 10,000 نقطه وخساره مكاسب
2022 كيف تقيم هذا المؤشر هذا العام
نعم اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير واهلا وسهلا
بكم طبعا نحنا زي ما احنا عارفين الانخفاض
تقريبا من بدايه السنه
وهو كما تفضلتم الادنى انخفاض بكثير
مقارنه بالاسواق العالميه لكن لا ننسى اخي
الكريم انه كثير من الاسهم انخفضت بين 50
و70% ووزن المؤشر تاسي يؤثر به تقريبا 20
شركه او نحوها يستحوذ على 90% من وزنه فقد
لا يكون خلينا نقول همم حركه المؤشر تعطي
انطباع حقيقي حول ما جرى على كثير من
اسعار الاسهم التي فقدت 50%
و70% بالمجمل احنا شفنا همم كانت في
ارتفاعات كبيره حقيقه السوق منذ ان كسر
حاجز 6,000 والس 6,000 نقطه في ما يسمى
كورونا حتى وصل الى مشاعر 14,000 نقطه كان
هذا كله جاء بعد نتائج قويه جدا
القطاع البتروكيميات وكثير من الاسهم
القياديه ممتاز نسبه الفائده كيف تغير
معها سوق الاسهم هل اثرت كذلك على شهيه
المستثمرين برايك لا شك انه اسعار الفائده
بشكل عام ترتبط بعلاقه بعلاقه عكسيه مع
اسواق المال اذا ما نظرنا الى الخيارات
والفرص البديله همم فيما يتعلق بالعائد
على الصكوك العائد على السندات العائد على
الوداع كل هذه يفضلها كثير من المستثمرين
كونها اقل من مخاطر ومضمونه ومقارنه
بعوائد الاسهم التي انخفضت بسبب بعض
النتائج الماليه غير الدائمه او همم جاء
بالمزامنه مع ارتفاع همم الفائده على كثير
من الخيارات الاستثماريه الاخرى وبالتالي
شفنا هبوط على اسعار عديد من الاسهم التي
استفاده همم سوق الاسهم السعوديه من الحجم
الطرحات
الاكتتابات الكبيره اللي حدث اكثر من 40
اكتتاب تقريبا حدث هذا العام همم
بالمناسبه طروحات الكثيره خلينا نقول تسحب
وتجفف السيوله وتهدئ من التضخم لكن فيما
يتعلق بشكل مباشر كاس اسواق المال لا شك
انها تعطي خيارات عديده للمستثمرين
تزيد من عمق السقى السعودي فلاشه كل ما
زادت الشركات بشتى انشطتها وتواجدها في
سوق الاسهم السعوديه اعطت خيارات عديده
للمستثمرين ممتازه نشاطات التداولي همم
لماذا انخفضت بشكل مفاجئ منذ الربع الثالث
هذا العام احنا شفنا قبل يمكن ثلاثه جلسات
سجل السوق السعودي ادنا السيوله في ثلاثه
سنوات بالضبط صحيح هذه لا شك انها السيوله
متدنيه فما اسلفت اخي الكريم انه دائما
ارتفاع اسعار الفائده يجفف السيوله من
الاسواق فهذا قد يكون هو ابرز اهم سبب ادى
الى انخفاض السيوله فاتفع اسعار الفائده
يفضل الكثير المستثمرين خروج امواله
ويضعها ياخذ عليها فوائد او البنوك او
الصكوك او سندات اضف الى ذلك انخفاض شهيا
المستمرين لاخذ همم فائده
الاسواق الماليه كونها اسعار الفائده صارت
كلتها خليني اسالك عن ادوات الدين
برايك كيف تمت الاستفاده ااا منها هذا
العام استاذ انس اييه بشكل عام كما اسلفت
انه ادوات الدين سواء كانت لي الحكومات او
للشركات كانت قد اخذت بفائده متدنيه سابقا
بعض اسعار الشركات كما ااا يعني نعلم
ارتفعت عليها التكاليف والتكاليف التمويل
بشكل كبير بعضها فضلت سدادها مبكرا اسباقا
ارتفاع اسعار فائده فيعني حقيقه فيه تباين
بين الشركات وفي بعضهم من اخذ بفائده
ثابته وبعضهم بفائده متغيره حتى فيما
يتعلق بالبنوك واستفادتها بشكل عام نكون
من ارتفاع اسعار الفائده الا انه بعض
البنوك قد يكون معظم او نصيب النصيب
الاكبر المحافظه الاهتمام عندهم كانت
تمويل لمحافظ الافراد وكلها بفائده ثابته
فبالتالي الاثر ما راح يكون كبير مقارنه
بمصاري اشكرك كثير شكرا من الرياض المختص
في سوق الاموال والاسهم